leur philosophie sauver la nature par
l'action directe mais sans violence 1971
lo ng greenpeace voile jours
sa mission faire stopper les essais
nucléaires ces moyens d actions chocs et
médiatisé mais toujours dans la non
violence
quitte à prendre des risques exemple
dans les années 80 où des militants
tentent d'empêcher le déversement de
déchets radioactifs en pleine mer et les
volontaires de greenpeace sont prêts à
risquer leur vie pour empêcher que les
flux soient jetés à la mer
c'est alors que l'un des fûts frappe un
canoë plein fouet et le volontaire à
bord et jeté à l'année
[Musique]
comment
sur les plateaux télé le représentant
français de greenpeace de l'époque se
défend de prendre des risques
inconsidérés
le risque en théorie est calculé à
savoir à savoir que nous n'aurions pas
les gens comme ça c'est à dire ce sont
des gens malades ou qui sont bien
équipés qui sont bien entraînées
également et nous postulons sur la
raison vous me direz c'est pas toujours
le cas on en a la démonstration
les années passent et les combats de
greenpeace se multiplient la fin du
nucléaire
l'arrêt de la chasse à la baleine aux
bébés phoques la protection de
l'environnement
avec toujours le même mode d'action une
confrontation directe et non violente
exemple en 2000 en gironde où des
militants s'enchaînent pour éviter
l'accostage d'un bateau rempli de soja
génétiquement modifiés
j'en connais un peu partout
pour remplacer le débarquement déjà
tranché
des militants enchaînés accroché sur une
tour de refroidissement d'une centrale
nucléaire ou encore en rappel au sein de
l'assemblée nationale
les coups d'éclat sont devenus la marque
de fabrique de l'omg
est ce que vous n'avez pas le sentiment
parfois de faire plus parler de vous que
des cause que vous défendez ou prend ce
risque là la plupart du temps on arrive
quand même à faire émerger notre message
aujourd'hui l'association pacifiste
compte trois millions trois cent mille
adhérents dans le monde dont 170 mille
en france
tous réunis par la même volonté de faire
réagir l'opinion publique par le biais
d'actions non violentes
[Musique]